My name is Putrian.
Uh I am a lieutenant in the Royal
Malaysia Navy
uh expertise in logistic uh ammunition
and explosive.
So as someone working in a male
dominated field, gender equality is a
widely discussed issue. One of the
challenges that I face is being denied
the same opportunities as my female
colleagues. With the justifications that
the environment is not safe for me,
issues like sexual harassment arise and
my ability to work freely just like men
becomes limited due to my safety
concerns. So my question is should I
accept this reasoning for the sake of my
own safety or should men be responsible
for creating a safer environment that
allows women to work without
limitations. Thank you.
>> My sister has asked a question
that many a time when she goes for a job
maybe she gets a lesser pay saying that
it may not be appropriate for you. It
may not be safe for you. So what should
she do? In short, sister, unless I don't
know which job you applying, how can I
say? Suppose you want to say that I want
to be a worker in the building in the
construction. So of course the men is
more safe, the woman, you know. So
depending on which type of job you
applying for. I cannot give you the
reply until you tell what type of job it
is. If it's a job specifically more
appropriate for men, for example, being
a helper and a laborer in the
construction, it's a job more for men.
If you want to knitting, embroidery or
basket making, more for the women. So
unless you don't tell me what the job
is, I cannot tell you whether you're
right or wrong. But if you're going for
a job which is equal for example you
want to do administration as long as the
administration facility is separate and
you have the hijab level no problem. So
that's why I'm telling you the society
where you're going depends on it. We ma
school Islamic international school
we have female teachers and male
teachers also depending upon their
qualification they get paid. Many a
times the female are put paid more than
the male.
So depending upon the ability and the
qualification what type of job they are
doing. So the salary is paid on the
ability not on the gender. So I don't
know you are qualified in which how can
I say whether they are doing justice to
you or not but if the qualification and
everything is same and if there is no
Sharia prohibition then the salary
should be same it should not differ
unfortunately in America if you read the
statistics the women are being paid less
what they say about 30% less it
previously was much less so this is the
discrimination in America. So that is
the reason
if you join an Islamic institute which
is following Quran and Sunnah that is
the best. Hope that's interesting.